I don't want anything for Christmas.
I think we ruin Christmas for ourselves
by putting pressure on ourselves to buy gifts for every single adult
we know. Your work friends,
your boss, your mother in law,
father in law, brother in law,
sister in law, your brothers,
your sisters, their spouses,
kids, teachers,
your friends, their spouses.
Why do we do this to ourselves?
Especially in this economy?
Yeah, like,
my husband will get me something.
That's great. My kids,
I hope they, like,
draw me a picture or something.
But everybody else, like, just.
Just come hang out with me.
Let's go out to dinner. Let's get, like,
chips and salsa and chat and have a game night.
Bring me, like,
a soda and we can hang out together.
That's all I want. I just want food and hanging out.
That's all I want from friends.
That's all I want from family members.
I think if we're all being honest,
that's what we all want to.
The real fun of Christmas is the children.
It's getting gifts for kids and watching them get excited.
That's what it's about.
Reason that people really get stressed out around the holidays
isn't really because of, like,
the little kids toys. It's because of these adult gifts
that we feel like we have to get somebody.
So it's just a PSA that if you don't give me a gift, that's okay.